[Música]
recuerden el patio de la escuela
una mañana del sol en un recreo
seguramente muchos podrán ver jóvenes
jugando abrazados escuchando música
un jueves de agosto de hace
no muchos años así nos encontrábamos en
el ipe entre 38 doctor salvador más
en el recreo de las diez y veinte
estábamos en el hall
con rosa
rosa merlo la directora
y un grupo de estudiantes
de repente ingresa la hermana de un
estudiante y nos dice los hijos se vamos
urgente hasta mi casa porque abrirse le
pasó algo
atravesamos el patio de la escuela y
llegamos a este lugar
en la puerta estaba el padre de brisa
y un grupo de mujeres que llorando
abraza las cosas
la hermana me sujeta el brazo e
ingresamos a la casita
al pasar por la cocina veo la camita de
brisa
un colchón sucio y sin fundas
su mochila
y una gallina para respaldar de su cama
continuamos así el patio
y al llegar al umbral de la puerta
de frena
levantó la mirada
y la beba brisa
y estudiante de tercer año colgada
tenía 16 años
conmovido la miró la hermana digo pero
qué haces porque me pone en este lugar
y el dolor me atravesó profundamente
la escuela del marqués anexo está
ubicada al noreste de la ciudad de
córdoba
donde la violencia construyó barreras
simbólicas
enfrentamientos entre grupos
que del 2009 al 2013 provocaron la
muerte de 28 jóvenes en diferentes
situaciones
balaceras muertes violentas suicidios
así se pueden ver hoy
y materializados
en muchos frentes de las casitas del
lugar pequeñas grutas
que con imágenes y objetos recuerdan la
vida de sus jóvenes
la escuela se quedó vacía
las madres por temor no enviaban sus
hijos a clases
sólo teníamos 4 o 5 estudiantes por aula
y no más de 50 en toda la escuela
en ese contexto
una mañana en la que se escucharon
disparos de bala ingresé a una mamá a
retirar a su hijo
tenía miedo
y en el pasillo de las aulas gritos
hagan algo por favor se están muriendo
nuestros jóvenes no se dan cuenta
lo abrazó lo besó
y se retiró por el hall atravesando una
cortina de luz
que en ese momento producía el sol en la
puerta de ingreso de la escuela
ya no queda más nada
la escuela vacía y en silencio
no podríamos seguir perdiendo
estudiantes
entonces interrumpimos las actividades
que se estaban desarrollando en las
aulas y llosa
la directora nos convocó a trabajar a
los 200 presentes a un espacio de
encuentro de empatía
hacer que florezca la palabra
como la respuesta correcta
decidimos
entonces decidimos
cambiar balas por palabras
[Aplausos]
surgieron hace un momento de motivación
que desde el patio de la escuela sonaban
los compases que empezaban a ser
escuchado en toda la comunidad
cacho y platillo marcaba en la presencia
de la murga estudiante vamos que
llegamos la escuela está viva y salimos
a la calle
el valor de la escucha respetuosa y las
palabras esponsable con unos alumnos
o frente a un alumno
como un acto de amor incondicional se
presentó en la actividad del cuento de
las mil grullas
se construyeron cientos de grullas de
papel con los valores de la escuela esos
valores de la escuela
que echaron a volar hacia cada familia
para anidar en el encuentro y
reproducirse en la comunidad
esos son los valores que llevamos desde
siempre
el encuentro
el abrazo el compañerismo el cumplir con
las tareas la responsabilidad enseñar
aprender
desde el arte y la literatura surgieron
cientos de trabajos con los chicos se
construyó una gran bandera blanca
para ser exhibida en la fachada de la
escuela
la frase del escritor que eduardo
galiano
otras realidades posibles y en el zócalo
escuela abierta comunidad unida
hermosa la bandera
el día 7 de mayo decidimos darle cierre
a todas estas actividades
7 de mayo del año 2013
convocamos a la familia docentes
estudiantes y autoridades a un acto
formal que no estaba previsto en el
calendario escolar
hubo palabras sentidas y profundas y
entre cada silencio se escuchaban de la
familia el nombre es de esos seres o
jóvenes queridos ausentes
para el momento del cierre salimos a la
puerta de la escuela hubo abrazos
lágrimas de esperanza y se soltaron
globos con palabras y frases de amor que
echaron a volar hacia la comunidad
un día domingo hablo con rosa
y le dije estuve buscando si existe una
ley que promocionen la palabra
la tienen no le encontré
entonces le sugerí
presentar este proyecto pedagógico de
una escuelita para llevarlo a la
legislatura y que se ha aprobado como
una ley
el miércoles 5 de junio del año 2013 en
la legislatura y la provincia de córdoba
por decisión unánime de todos los
bloques
se aprobó la ley número 10 1150 ley de
promoción de la palabra y la
no-violencia en el espacio público
[Aplausos]
la ley de la convivencia
la ley
del encuentro de la familia con la
escuela más tarde adhirió el consejo
deliberante para las escuelas
municipales primarias y la universidad
nacional de córdoba para la educación
superior
la escuela aprendió
a cambiar balas por palabras
surgieron así
proyectos en donde tienen amplia
participación
de la escuela y la comunidad y giro a un
sentido la escuela hacia trabajar el
proyecto con la comunidad
hoy con más de 300 estudiantes
un nuevo ciclo orientado ante uno tarde
programa inclusión y terminalidad para
jóvenes de 14 y 17 años
programa de formación laboral en oficio
de habilidades sociales donde más de 550
jóvenes
certifican competencias por el ámbito
laboral
la escuela abierta a los 360 días al año
disponibles escuela de verano escuela de
invierno donde más de 200 niños y
jóvenes realizan actividades culturales
deportivas recreativas
con la academia solidaria de arte
encuentro palabra
danzas tejidos
y todas las actividades que tienen que
ver con la cultura con la universidad
nacional de córdoba la universidad siglo
el fortalecimiento de las trayectorias
estudiantiles una para el ciclo básico y
la otra para el ciclo orientado que
representan estos logros una escuela
presente
la escuela presente que se involucra
así como cuando tuvimos que ir con rosa
y una familia
a buscarla es la pista de brisa de la
morgue
buscar su cajón su tapa y su nicho de
escuela
también preparar mi auto poner demonios
y llevar a mi estudiante lucía de tercer
año al paseo del buen pastor a sacarse
la foto de los 15 años
regresar a la fiesta y entregarla de la
mano a la familia
[Aplausos]
la escuela presente que convoca cada 7
de mayo de todos los años convocamos a
la familia y a las instituciones del
lugar
a recuperar ese momento de promoción de
la palabra y el encuentro una escuela
presente que construye confianza
desde el año 2013 personalmente y muchas
veces me acompañase a la directora
espero a mis estudiantes
en la esquina verlos llegar a la mañana
las madres me saludan desde la distancia
como señal de que aquí le dejamos o le
entregamos a nuestras joyas más
preciadas que son nuestros hijos son los
primeros abanderados de la familia
y una escuela presente que motiva
para que no sea lo único y lo último que
tenemos
como la expresó
la mamá karina
qué es la escuela
la escuela construye proyectos de vida
en valores
para que la historia no se repita
y para que la puedan escribir con
libertad
me preguntaron por qué lo hace josé o
por qué lo hacen
primero por un fuerte compromiso con la
vida
es terrible ver que jóvenes que quedan
fuera del sistema educativo
por diferentes motivos pierden la vida
en un encuentro con un educador estando
con rosa nos dijo
ustedes no tienen ni idea no tienen
noción a los jóvenes que les salvaron la
vida que lograron que terminen el
secundario y que hoy tienen familias
hermosas
por un compromiso con la educación de
ellos de formar jóvenes ciudadanos
democráticos con las capacidades y las
habilidades para poder desempeñarse en
el mundo laboral o continuar con
estudios superiores
y por un compromiso con la familia
la escuela promovió
escuchen la escuela promovió una nueva
categoría educativa el oficio de familia
de estudiantes
así como se fortalece el oficio de
estudiante y se trabaja en el
fortalecimiento del oficio de enseñante
o en las capacitaciones de docentes
al integrar a la familia a todos los
proyectos pedagógicos de la escuela para
aquellos que no tuvieron la posibilidad
determinar el nivel primario y mucho
menos el secundario
acompañamos a las familias para que
puedan desarrollar sus hijos
la trayectoria continua y regular en la
escuela
a nuestras
estudiantes mamá papá
y también estudiante embarazada todos
los finales de años le entregamos la
matrícula dorada
que representa la matrícula dorada
un doble compromiso con la escuela
primero sus hijos ya están matriculados
para el año 2026 2027 con el banco
reservado para primer año
ellas ya transitaron la escuela y
terminaron el secundario por lo tanto
damos por descontado de que con el
acompañamiento de la escuela lo vamos a
lograr
la escuela ya construyó ya sentó las
bases de los oficios
de estudiante y de familia
imagino el día
en el que en ese mismo hall
donde no busco
la hermana de brisa rosa ya mí
donde esa mamá gritó hagan algo
ingresé por primera vez un estudiante
con su mamá para mostrarnos su título
universitario y nos diga lo logramos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah